hey this is presh tolwalker here's a
puzzle that's gone viral in the
mathematical Community bottle plus
bottle plus bottle is equal to 30.
bottle plus Burger plus Burger is equal
to 20. Burger plus two beers plus two
beers is equal to nine
what is the value of the integral from
Burger plus Burger minus bottle to
Infinity of the fraction bottle
multiplied by sign of hot dog divided by
the quantity two beers multiplied by hot
dog D hot dog
I thank Phil for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
let's get started on these equations
we have three bottles is equal to Thirty
and that means each bottle is equal to
ten
now let's use this value for the next
equation
bottle plus two burgers is equal to
twenty
so we have ten plus two burgers is equal
to twenty that means two burgers is
equal to ten and one Burger is equal to
five
we'll substitute this value into the
third equation
so we have 5 plus a total of 2
multiplied by two beers is equal to nine
that means two multiplied by two beers
is equal to four and so two beers is
equal to two
we'll now substitute these values into
the integral so we have the integral
from Burger plus Burger minus bottle to
Infinity a bottle multiplied by sine hot
dog divided by two beers multiplied by
hot dog D hot dog
so Burger plus Burger minus bottle is
equal to five plus five minus ten which
is equal to zero that's the lower limit
we'll substitute that in
then bottle is equal to ten so we can
substitute that value in two beers are
equal to two we substitute that in
now hot dog is a placeholder variable so
we can replace it by X so we have sine X
Two X and DX
let's now clean up this integral
we just need to evaluate this value now
10 divided by 2 is equal to 5 so we have
a constant here so we have 5 multiplied
by sine X divided by X we can take 5
outside of this integral and so the key
thing we need to evaluate is the
integral from 0 to Infinity of sine X
divided by X DX this is a very famous
integral and it's known as the dirichlet
integral there are many ways to evaluate
it it's actually very difficult to be
completely rigorous but I'll do my best
in this video to present one way to
evaluate this integral
so let's work this out the first thing
is we're going to need a magic trick we
will first look at the integral from 0
to Infinity of e to the power of
negative X Y multiplied by sine X d y
these kinds of integrals come up in
differential equations so as they were
studied people notice connections with
other Concepts so let's just evaluate
this integral first sine X is a constant
with respect to Y so we could bring it
outside of the integral
We Now integrate e to the power of
negative X Y with respect to Y this is
equal to e to the power of negative X Y
divided by negative X and we want to
evaluate this from 0 to Infinity
now the limit as y goes to Infinity of e
to the power of negative Y is equal to
zero and e to the power of zero is equal
to one
so we can substitute in that this is
equal to zero divided by negative x
minus one divided by negative X which
all simplifies to be sine X divided by X
so this integral is exactly equal to
sine X divided by X
if we integrate both sides from 0 to
Infinity with respect to X we then get
exactly the integral that we want
so the integral we want is equal to this
double integral
so how do we evaluate that
it's very difficult to evaluate this
double integral so there's a natural
trick we use when we work out double
integrals
the trick is to change the order of
integration
however e to the power of negative XY
multiplied by sine X doesn't satisfy our
normal conditions for fobini serum
evaluated from 0 to Infinity over Y and
X so we will refer to another theorem so
I'll just put it up on the screen and
there's a paper that you can look to for
all the details but there are specific
conditions which will allow you to
change the order of integration that
would apply for this particular problem
you just go ahead and check that those
conditions are satisfied and then we're
on proper grounding to change the order
of integration
so we will change the order of
integration to get the double integral
going from zero to Infinity 0 to
Infinity of e to the power of negative X
Y multiplied by sine x d x d y
so now how do we evaluate this
the first trick we'll use is that we'll
write sine X in terms of Euler's
function so sine X can be substituted as
e to the power of i x minus e to the
power of negative IX all over 2i
from here we can multiply the
exponentials so we have e to the power
of negative X multiplied by y minus I
minus e to the power of negative X
multiplied by y plus I
this is d x d y where the limits go from
0 to Infinity 0 to infinity and we pull
out this one over two I
from here we will integrate these
exponentials with respect to X
so let's just focus on this integral
so let's evaluate what's inside
so we remember that the limit as X goes
to Infinity of e to the power of
negative X is equal to zero and e to the
power of zero is equal to one
so this is all going to simplify
tremendously we're going to get 0 minus
then we subtract out the quantity 1 over
negative y plus I minus 1 divided by
negative y minus I
as it turns out these denominators are
complex conjugates of each other so in
order to get a common denominator we
multiply each fraction by the
denominator of the other
so we're going to end up with negative
negative y minus I divided by this
denominator plus negative y plus I
divided by the same denominator
each denominator is going to work out to
be 1 plus y squared so we can combine
the numerators
then the Y terms are going to cancel out
so this all works out to be 2i divided
by 1 plus y squared what is
simplification
so this integral will be equal to 1
divided by 2i multiplied by the integral
of 0 to Infinity of 2i divided by 1 plus
y squared d y now the two I terms will
cancel out so this is equal to the
integral from 0 to Infinity of 1 divided
by 1 plus y squared d y this is a
standard integral this is equal to the
arc tangent of Y and one evaluate that
from 0 to Infinity now the limit as y
goes to Infinity of arctangent of Y is
equal to pi over 2 and then the
arctangent of 0 is equal to zero so we
get pi over 2 minus zero and this is
equal to pi over 2.
so we figured out that the integral from
0 to Infinity of sine X divided by X DX
is equal to pi over 2. of course we need
5 times this integral so we multiply
both sides of the equation by 5 and this
is equal to 5 pi divided by 2. so what's
the answer to our puzzle you could write
it as 5 pi over 2 or 2.5 Pi but I think
it's much more appropriate to write it
in terms of emojis so the correct answer
is two pi's and a half and that's the
answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of buying your decisions where
we solve The World's problems one video
at a time
[Music]